[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
the terrifying moment as a driver rams
into a mother and her baby girl
the heroic bystanders and officers
lifting the vehicle off the infant
grab the baby how one woman's ingenuity
on a dating app
led the fbi to a capital riot suspect
accused of pepper spraying and beating
officers with a whip
and police identifying the suspected
rapist and killer of a 14 year old girl
the cold case solved thanks to the help
of donations from an unexpected source
sometimes it's just the little things
that you can do that you know make a
difference
plus horrific details as the jury learns
how college student samantha josephson
was murdered after getting into the
wrong car thinking it was her uber ride
this is the weapon lawn crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
two police officers in yonkers new york
help bystanders lift a car
off of a baby and it's all caught on
camera anjanet levy is here with video
of dramatic rescue
brian these officers were just getting
breakfast in a bagel shop when they
heard that loud crash
and they sprang into action to
investigate
last friday it was a sunny morning in
yonkers when a 36 year old woman
started to cross the street with her
eight-month-old daughter
then yonkers police say a suspected
drunk driver came out of nowhere
striking a car and plowing the mother
and baby into a shop
four or three headquarters we got a baby
under the vehicle body camera video from
officer paul samayedny shows people
trying to lift the car
off of the baby
the scene chaotic as the officers and
witnesses work to rescue the infant
grab the baby
[Music]
officer rocco fusco's body camera showed
a different view of the rescue
baby
now that baby suffered a skull fracture
and third degree burns her mother
suffered a fracture to her leg and they
are both
thankfully expected to survive that
driver who hit them his name is david
poncurak and he faces several
charges including driving while
intoxicated brian
thanks and jeanette joining us today is
criminal defense attorney mike corebonix
and terry austin mike vehicular assault
and driving while intoxicated
how bad are these charges what kind of
time is this guy looking at
these are bad charges he's got a maximum
of 15 years he's looking at but
there it's going to be interesting to
see what his blood alcohol level was and
things of that nature but
it appears there's going to be a lot of
aggravating factors to this case
because of the nature of it i mean this
is midday it looks
you know daylight i shouldn't say midday
i don't know exactly the time but it's
just
very scary yeah if the if the time stamp
on the video is correct it's 8
29 a.m so being intoxicated that early
is definitely something that prosecution
will look
very poorly on and of course the nature
of the victims
and jeanette what evidence do the police
have to support the driving while
intoxicated charge
well brian the yonkers police said on
its facebook page that they found
an alcoholic beverage inside the vehicle
so not only are they saying that he was
intoxicated
but that they found an actual alcoholic
drink in the car which is
really bad news and they also did a
blood alcohol test we don't know the
results of that yet but we have to
assume that the police have a good idea
of what that might be
and sometimes those tests depending on
when they're run can take a few weeks
yeah and the blood alcohol content of
the state of new york the legal limit is
point zero eight as is much
uh are many states in this country so if
he's above that
that's we're you're gonna see that dwi
charge that comes up in his
uh charging documents thank you everyone
turning now to other top legal news
colorado prosecutors now say a husband
accused of murdering his wife
used a spy pen to secretly record her
susan morphy was reported missing by her
neighbor on mother's day 2020.
her husband barry murphy pleaded for her
safe return on social media
but a year later was charged with
killing her his arrest won't remain
sealed for now
but at a recent hearing prosecutors
revealed there's a rough audio from a
spy pen
in which susan can be heard talking to a
man on the phone
morpheus being held in jail without bail
a grand jury has indicted a man accused
of murdering three people and leaving
their bodies on a georgia golf course
brian rhoden is now facing 15 charges
including malus murder
felony murder and aggravated assault
according to the indictment
roden kidnapped two of the victims
gagging them and binding their hands
with duct tape before throwing them into
the bed of a pickup truck
prosecutors say roden drove onto the
pine tree golf course
shot the man then shot golf pro gene
siller who happened upon the scene
rhoden is due back in court later this
week
r b singer r kelly is facing serious
allegations
ahead of the anticipated start of his
new york trial prosecutors in brooklyn
are accusing kelly
of sexually abusing a 17 year old boy
nearly 15 years ago
according to newly filed court documents
kelly invited the boy to his chicago
recording studio
under the guise of mentoring him then
engaged in sexual contact with him
prosecutors are asking a judge to allow
evidence from the alleged assault in at
trial
as an uncharged act r kelly's trial is
scheduled to begin
in august still ahead on law and crime
daily the surprising donation police say
helped crack a decades-old cold case of
a teenage girl
found raped and murdered but first the
latest capital riot arrest how a dating
app helped catch a suspect accused of
assaulting officers
and the woman the fbi is now thinking
after the break
welcome back federal prosecutors are
crediting the help of a woman
on a dating app to help catch a suspect
accused of beating officers
with a whip during the january 6 capital
insurrection
according to court records the woman
tipped off the fbi that anjutake
messaged her on the app
bumble sending her a picture of himself
after being sprayed by officers
investigators say they then match take
up to a suspect
wanted for pepper spring police in front
of a bike rack barricade the agent goes
on to say that less than an hour later
take use the metal whip to beat more
officers surveillance video also
allegedly shows take inside the building
with other rioters
take was arrested on friday for charges
of obstruction assault and disorderly
conduct
back with us to discuss the man who
probably wishes he swiped left
is criminal defense attorney mike
corbonix and terry austin
terry dating apps provide gps so with
that and the photos
does this sound like an airtight case
for the prosecution
you know it's pretty airtight brian what
they want to do is corroborate
all of the information together both the
circumstantial and the direct the direct
evidence being you know the factual
evidence and the
you know circumstantial evidence being
the inferences that they can make and so
what they're going to want to do
is take video they want to use the
photos they want to use witnesses they
want to use
everything from the app and put that all
together just to make sure they can put
everyone together in one place and
really point the finger to make this
a very airtight case now mike i'll let
your son explain dating apps to you
later but
these dating app messages can they be
used against the defendant in court
absolutely but i was on the phone with
my son i'm sorry
no yeah absolutely in court i mean
people have to realize
that prosecutors now use cell phones
as like just an endless supply of
evidence people could be
told what time and place they're at and
those are not
confidential or protected statements you
make on dating apps anything that's open
to the public
so this is another case and we talk
about it often brian how when defendants
go out and brag about what they do it's
the best evidence the prosecution has
against them
hey i found love on a dating app it
seems like this person is going to find
a different type of love with the
criminal justice system so
we'll see how this continues for this
defendant as bumble seems to have stung
him in more ways than one
turning now to las vegas where a 32 year
old cold case is solved
thanks to a generous donation and dna
testing angina libya is back and has
more on the man
who paid for the testing angenette brian
las vegas metro police say they now know
who killed stephanie isaacson back in
1989 and
interestingly enough a donation from a
restaurant owner helped crack the case
for decades stephanie isaacson's family
and detectives have wanted to know who
took her life
she left her home for school on june 1st
1989
and never made it at autopsy
we learned that stephanie had
significant blunt force trauma injuries
and that she had been sexually assaulted
the clark county coroner's office ruled
her death as a result of strangulation
but thanks to a company called othram
they now know we have identified darren
roy marchand who has been positively
identified as the person who sexually
assaulted
and murdered stephanie othram conducted
dna testing
identifying marchand through genetic
genealogy
with an incredibly small amount of dna
in january of 2021
the forensic lab in conjunction with our
cold case homicide team
submitted the remaining evidence that we
had which had very little dna
left the equivalent of 15 cells was
submitted for this testing
justin wu's generous donation helped
crack the case
in many ways i'm glad that we were able
to you know that it was successful in
finding someone and matching the
murderer to the you know to the case
wu said the owner of othram approached
him about sponsoring a case
the restaurateur now a bit of a crime
fighter
it's weird and sometimes it's just the
little things that you can do that
you know make a difference while police
know who killed stephanie
sadly marchand will never be held
accountable he died by suicide in 1995.
police read a statement from the young
girl's mother
i'm glad they found who murdered my
daughter i never believed the case would
be solved
it's good to have some closure but there
is no justice for stephanie at all
police say that darren marchand had
actually been arrested
for another murder three years before
stephanie
was killed that murder charge was
actually dropped for a lack of evidence
and las vegas police had conducted dna
testing several times over the years but
they didn't get that match
until they went the route of genetic
genealogy earlier this year
brian thanks engineer and of course the
compassionate donation of that
restaurant tour
coming up on law and crime daily the
fake uber murder trial will a defendant
accused of murdering a young woman in
the back of his
seat of his car take the stand in his
own defense find out
next
[Music]
welcome back we head to south carolina
where both sides have rested
without the defendant taking the stand
in the trial of a man accused of
murdering a college student who
allegedly got into his car
thinking it was her uber ride
twenty-seven-year-old nathaniel roland
is charged with kidnapping and murdering
21 year old samantha josephson
josephson was last seen on surveillance
video around 2am
in march 2019 leaving a bar and getting
into a black vehicle
according to the autopsy josephson
suffered more than 120 stab wounds
and cuts to much of her body on the
stand the forensic pathologist
identified a multi-tool knife with two
blades that belonged to the defendant
as the murder weapon the parallel
cuts are made by this did you see some
singular stab wounds as well
yes yes and many in fact the majority of
the stab wounds were singular stab
wounds
once this is pulled apart
like this now it's a single bladed
weapon
so that's one of the things that was
confusing me as the autopsy was i
thought there must be
two weapons because there was the
parallel blade
ones and then there were the single ones
so i thought it's unusual to have two
weapons
but now i think it's explained it's
explained to my satisfaction that this
is the
this is the the knife in this
confirmation
would make the parallel wounds that i
saw and then
if it's in this confirmation it could
then make the
single stat wounds the forensic
pathologist
then gave his opinion on what caused
samantha josephson's death
she's going to bleed out she's going to
bleed out she said
yes sir okay one of the neck wounds
involves the carotid artery and the
jugular vein
that wound would produce a lot of blood
flow
she had a defect in her hyoid bone on
the right side
in her case though i'm not of the
opinion that it's
a strangulation i think it came from one
of the stab wounds to her neck
the knife actually got up high enough to
sever the highway bone i couldn't tell
you absolutely there was no
manual strangulation involved but i can
tell you i i would
favor the that it was done by a knife by
the staff
do you have a an opinion right now that
you can tell this jury
of what caused samantha josephson's
death yes
multiple stab wounds i made the cause of
death multiple stab wounds
when we come back cross-examination how
will the forensic pathologist hold up
when questioned by the defense
and the key piece of evidence the
defense says is missing next
back now to the south carolina murder
trial of nathaniel roland
an expert has said the victim's dna was
found under his fingernails but
that his dna was not found under hers
defense attorneys wanted to know
more about the victim's fingernail
clippings taken at autopsy
in your report you indicated that they
were medium length
at the time okay today you're telling us
that
you thought they were fairly short and
length well they were
they're not long let's put it that way
so i was
in the idea of getting dna under your
fingernails
long fingernails are will
be more effective in getting some kind
of dna under your fingernails than short
ones
so hers are medium length so um probably
a little bit longer than mine
but you were able to notice with the
nails that she had
evidence of tearing that's what you put
in your report correct yes
then the defense asked the medical
examiner how he could be so
certain that multi-tool was in fact the
murder weapon
i had not seen the weapon before it was
presented to me today
so i did not know that it opened up
until i saw
this morning but you've been told
you had a conversation with the
prosecutors
in preparation for trial where you did a
discussion about this
multi-tool was was had right yes that
was
like a few days ago and that
and during that conversation you would
say that
some of the wounds are consistent with
being made by the open the multi
tool in the open position and some in
the closed
position correct you didn't get a
you didn't get a picture of the weapon
at that time no and
in fact i sent law enforcement a picture
that i thought might be the weapon
just from my search of thousands and
thousands of images of knives
and but it turned out to be something
entirely different
interesting on redirect by the
prosecution the medical
examiner explained how some of the
victim's stab wounds could be longer
than the length of the blade
the hilt of the knife the handle pushes
in on the soft tissue and allows the
blade to go
deeper into the soft tissues so it's
it's it's fairly common to see
wounds deeper than the length of the
blade
particularly on the abdomen and on the
chest area but also on the thigh where
where there's a lot of soft tissue that
can be compressed by the hilt
of the handle of the knife and you saw
that in this case
um i did not see that hilt or handle
mark which is sometimes good for us to
see
but that's what i measured it when i put
the probe in
and i pulled it out and i put it against
the ruler that's what the
length was how long would it take a
person to die from these wounds
the injuries to the brain and the
carotid artery
are fairly severe and would the bleeding
would be profuse
and very rapid so
um i would say a matter of minutes
maybe 10 or 15 minutes maybe 20.
now mike the dna under or not under
certain fingernails depending on who
you're looking at
it makes me think maybe it's just a
theory i'm throwing out there
roland was there but didn't kill
joseph's son that she
fought and scratched the person who
stabbed her but maybe it's not him what
do you think can the defense work with
any of this
they could work with it but i don't
think it's going to carry the day i
think it's an easy explanation that
you know there's no evidence or no
evidence was presented of any scratching
or anything like that
on the defendant you know you would
think you'd see something like that if
you wanted to bring it to some sort of
relevance
uh there was none i think it's just i
think it may be like a red herring type
of thing brian because it could be very
well he was wearing long sleeve shirts
while she was fighting back or a
sweatshirt
and she didn't get to his skin but to
that point then
should there be i don't know some fabric
under her fingernails like if you
scratch in my my suit
i would think that my suit has my dna on
it you might get some of my dna or even
some
parts of my suit could that be another
route the defense goes
it could be but it just seems that the
the
the
the pile up of evidence and the way
these circumstances
get better and better for the
prosecution with each witness i i don't
think it would really
be a game-changing type of uh type of a
point to bring out agree now terry this
case
went by pretty quickly uh and the
interesting part is
both sides have rested but the defense
never put on a case
the defendant didn't testify understand
that's his right but no
evidence no witnesses no nothing to kind
of feed us
this information that they put on the
opening statement that he was passed out
somewhere so
how's this going to work out for the
defense i think so far
the defense has made very little headway
and if they aren't putting on a case
which they are not
they did not make any headway with any
of the cross-examinations
so they basically repeated what the
prosecution said on most of the direct
examinations so for instance as it
related to the weapon
she just repeated well did you know what
kind of weapon it was and did you talk
to the prosecution about the weapon
and he said he did but she tried to make
it seem like there was a problem with
having that discussion there was no
problem with that discussion
and dr baker was very clear
whatever weapon killed our victim here
no question that it was two-sided
parallel blades and then one-sided so
this
weapon fit the exact evidence that we
have on samantha's body so
i don't think that the defense made
headway with the cross-examinations of
the main witnesses and they certainly
haven't made any headway because
they've rested and they aren't bringing
on any witnesses they have no
explanation
so as we all know terry the defense can
only argue what came
in at trial what came in through direct
or cross-examination or
through their witnesses none here so
what can the defense argue at the
summation of this trial
they can't argue very much brian you and
i were talking about this they brought
up some information
during their opening that maybe the
defendant was asleep and someone else
used his car but they've not put on any
information to that effect
and they cannot argue that at summation
so
i don't know what they're going to say
it's going to be very interesting to
hear
what arguments they are going to make
because every single bit of evidence
goes against the defendant here
all right trial order dismissal has
happened the judge denied that we'll see
how this continues
with closing statements next thank you
both for joining us and thank you for
joining us here at law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you